i mean life is a journey and you want to
be excited about what you're doing
so find passion in it and if you find
passion as they say you'll never
work a day in your life
[Music]
shelley brunswick thank you for joining
me on 20 minute leaders how are you
i'm fantastic it's wonderful to join you
today thank you for inviting me and
thank you to your sponsors that make
this possible
thank you very very much that's very
kind of you and good morning to you
thank you for taking this
on an early sunday morning a but we're
going to have so much fun it's going to
be the best sunday morning
possible because we're going to talk all
about space your passion
i know practically nothing about space
and i'm
and i'm ultra curious so i'm excited for
this
episode shelly if i were to even start
by going
through your journey from the air force
all the way to the space foundation
i'm not gonna do it justice so i'm gonna
ask you to briefly take me through
your your incredible experiences and so
that we can get into a deeper
conversation about about space and
and where we're headed well thank you
for that
i always like to say my journey has had
three chapters
and that first chapter was right out of
high school i enlisted in the u.s
air force and i was stationed in europe
and so i got to experience you know new
cultures new people new ideas
and while i was working during the day i
was a personnel office uh specialist so
hr and at night i went to school so i
completed my bachelor's degree going to
school at night and after being enlisted
for 12 years
i applied and was selected to become a
air force officer so that
started my second journey and that's
when i transitioned into the aerospace
and space industry because i was
stationed
at the space and missile system center
in los angeles
and i became a space project manager so
that was really my start
and then from there i had jobs working
at the space missile system center
learning all about ground stations and
launch vehicles and on-orbit assets and
then i went and worked at the
physician university i was a professor
teaching about space acquisition
and then my final uh assignment in the
air force i was stationed on capitol
hill
where i was a congressional budget and
appropriations liaison
securing the budget for the air force as
well as the space
portion of that budget and then
answering questions and and helping
everyone understand the importance of
space to our future
and then so that ends my second chapter
and obviously you know a little bit
about my third chapter
and that's where i am today working at
the space foundation as the chief
operating officer and
our executive leader for our center for
innovation and education
that's just remarkable one of the things
that he mentioned was and it sounds to
resonate across your careers
is what part of your role was also
explaining the importance of space
and how people can interact with such a
a weird subject right
because you know 99 of the things that
we deal with are here on earth and all
of a sudden we're dealing with things
that we can't even see
feel or touch or hear and one of the
things that you know we brought up in
our earlier discussion was how
a lot of people view space as sort of
like a black box right and
and as an engineer when i get introduced
to you know to a lot of code
that is sometimes it's very complicated
somebody else wrote it and i just
accepted it as it is i'm too i'm not
i'm too afraid to even get into it and
touch it because it's so messy and
complicated
and i think that for me and my friends
space is
like that in some level it's too obscure
it's too complicated out there
so maybe dumb it down a little bit for
me and talk to you a little bit about
what space
really is all about well
that's one of the misperceptions about
space there are three real
misperceptions you know one is the
technology piece of it
many people think about elon musk and
jeff bezos
and launch vehicles and satellites and
that is certainly
a part of the space industry but i read
about your background as well and you're
very sophisticated and smart and you're
doing a lot of things that directly
relate to space
because space is about the internet of
things uh
financial industry agriculture
healthcare pharmaceuticals
public safety transportation
communications
there are 16 different technology
sectors that relate to the space
industry
and we're using them every day we're
using it right now when we get done
we're probably all going to look at our
cell phone technology and your cell
phone came from the space industry
and i share with you two awesome um
companies went public
and that was uber eats or doordash
and airbnb again two great companies
that are using space technology to
create a company so
when you think about it don't think
about it like this is space
and it's a black box think about it as
how can i take this
this um capability this infrastructure
and how can i use it to unlock value
release innovation and technology to
help better our lives on earth so i hope
that helped a little bit
and how exciting space is and what
really the space economy is
so so shelly why are you so passionate
about space why join the air force
out of high school why continue on the
path and you know you're you're
touching the skies with the airplane and
then you decide to go even higher to
space why why even do that
why go that route
well i have a value system that was
instilled from a very early age
um my grandmother my mother uh my aunts
they're we're all we all come from a
family of you know we really work hard
we believe
in uh doing what's right uh integrity
first service before self
and those are exactly the same traits
that the u.s air force has
so it was a natural path for me to go
into the air force i
i initially didn't think i'd stay almost
30 years but i just
loved what i was doing and i'm
passionate about everything i do i mean
life
is a journey and you want to be excited
about what you're doing
so find passion in it and if you find
passion as they say you'll
never work a day in your life so i love
what i do
i think um the biggest piece for me is
i look at all the individuals um that
maybe are not part of the space economy
and i
highlight we have room for everyone
whether it's high school diploma to phd
there's an opportunity for everyone to
be part of the space economy
talk to me a little bit about where we
are today because i think
one of the remarkable things that we've
seen in the past year or two
is this explosion of innovation and
excitement over what's been happening
with space i know hundreds of thousands
are tuning in live
practically daily for the spacex
launches uh
jeff bezos his company origins just
announced a partnership with nasa
right to deploy to deploy things to
space so where are we today
in terms of either space exploration or
space technology
you know just to give me a little bit of
taste so that i can get excited about it
awesome well let me give you a little
bit of taste i'm sure you're very
familiar with gps
and when people think about gps they
think about airplanes and they think
about you know
cars and how do we get from one place to
the other but since 1983
gps has unlocked 1.3 trillion dollars of
value to our economy
that's jobs that's um economic
opportunity
and again i shared with you a couple of
companies that have just come public
that are using space technology to
create a business
so get excited about that because the
other great part of gps
is that was an investment by the us
government so that
infrastructure was courtesy of the us
government
anybody anywhere in the world can use
gps now to create a business
and be an entrepreneur the other great
thing is
uh the nasa technology transfer office
has thousands of patents
that are waiting for entrepreneurs to
bring to market
water purification growing food in
austere conditions
communications battery and storage
technology
so you can go to the nasa technology
transfer office and if you don't
have an idea on being an entrepreneur
you can take and apply for one of their
patents they also have seed money
to help you get started so again
space technology solves problems here on
earth and makes our lives better
and and for anybody any of your
listeners in europe also the european
space agency has the same thing
the technology transfer office so if you
want to be an entrepreneur
and you don't currently have an idea
most entrepreneurs kind of have an idea
you can go to either of those websites
and find a patent
and try to bring it public and and solve
problems here on earth
i think that's just fascinating because
so many times i'm watching my friends
you know go through this this you know
really difficult ideation process where
they're sitting down thinking
what can i invent or what can i do to
make a positive impact and even if i do
think i can make an impact can i even
invent the technology to go and do that
let alone write a patent about it and
just hearing that you have this
this scene obviously phenomenal agency
of superstars
that have already thought up these
really obscure and weird problems to
solve
uh such as water purification growing
food in austere places
and there there might be open to you in
coming and making it and productizing
and making a business out of it
i have to go check it out because it's
super super cool but i have to ask
shelly
along your career did you anticipate
that you're going to become
a space woman and such a strong advocate
you know going to capitol hill and
advocating for either its funding or
support
is this a path that you imagined for
yourself
i would never have imagined this for
myself you have to remember when i
started over 30 years ago the space
industry was very different than it is
today
when i started you worked for the
government and it was really
a few only a few countries even had
space programs and it was really about
outer space
you know low earth orbit with where the
shuttle is
satellites ground stations since
the 80s just to now you can see the
commercialization and it started with
the right legislation
that allowed commercialization of launch
vehicles
but it also showed all this other
technology
and so we've gone from a few countries
to over 80 countries are now part of the
space economy and that's continuing to
grow
and it went from where you worked for
the government or maybe a large company
that worked for the government to now
you can be an entrepreneur
and bring products to market yourself so
we've seen this democratization
and the opportunity again for everyone
to be part of this space economy so
it's an exciting time for me there's no
way uh
little shelley brunswick could have
imagined this but i'm excited and i look
forward to whatever the next thing is
when people say what do you think the
next thing is it's like
who could ever thought gps would be what
it is today
and so it's exciting no no
that that's what's phenomenal so shelley
all of that sounds
super exciting and you know i never
pictured
when i think of all the different paths
that my my career could take me i don't
think that i even considered space
as a viable option and you know i think
that as a t
you know growing up as a teen a lot of
the times when we talked about space we
all immediately thought of the
connotation of being an astronaut and
i remember that when i watched the movie
hidden figures which i'm sure that
you're very familiar with
and i think it really transformed my my
thinking about about what different
opportunities are
there are to be as a scientist and not
necessarily as as the athlete
scientist that is going up in the space
shuttle and now i'm definitely
reconsidering a lot of a lot of
different paths that i could take but
chile
i'd love for you to tell me a little bit
about where we're headed what is
what are the next steps in in either
space exploration discovery
scientifically speaking
and and what can i get excited about for
the next 10 years or so
well it's really exciting what i do want
to share is
the space economy is currently 424
billion dollars
and that's projected to grow one to
three trillion dollars by 2040.
and bank of america came out last month
and said they're predicting
the global space economy to be 1.3
trillion dollars by 2030.
so there's lots of opportunities and
that growth again
is not just going to be in the launch
vehicles and satellites it's going to be
here on earth
with data analytics and cyber and
miniaturization of
technology and advanced manufacturing
and healthcare
so that you're going to see this
awesome explosion we'll use that term of
space
technology being used in our daily lives
here on earth
uh the space foundation has a program we
call space technology hall of fame
and every year we recognize space
technology
that has been commercialized to help
human beings on earth
this year we recognize telehealth
telecommunications and teleconferencing
all technology that came from the space
program that has made this year of coven
even um achievable because when you
think about
healthcare and communications without
those forms
of space technology this year of covid
would have been very very
challenging even more challenging than
it is now and it is extremely
challenging for many folks
i i couldn't even imagine what would
happen if kobut had
broken out you know in even in the early
2000s
or even 10 years ago right i mean it's a
i mean a lot of the of our ability to
adapt
and to maintain for the for for some to
some degree our daily routine
work work life balance and family habits
are due to these technologies and so so
it's very remarkable
tell me a little bit about the space
foundation and your work over there
besides everything that we talked about
you're also a role model for for so many
women
whether it's through the awards you
received or your mentorship in the
different
programs like a space for space for
women i believe
right and so i i would love to hear a
little bit about
about your work as a mentor but also as
part of the space foundation
well wonderful one of the activities i
lead at the space foundation is our
center for
innovation and education and that is all
about creative inclusive
sustainable programs for workforce
development and economic opportunity
so all individuals can find their place
in the space economy
and again i shared with you that's the
entire workforce pipeline k-12
teaching teachers re-skilling the
workforce
and then entrepreneurship so we're
looking at the entire workforce pipeline
because to grow that space economy one
to three trillion dollars
we need everybody to look at space as a
real opportunity so
that's why i'm out here talking with you
today and thank you for giving me this
chance
to get that awareness out there that
space is possible
for everyone we can help you find your
way into the space economy
and and then we do have a workforce
development roadmap awareness is number
one which we're doing today
access i just shared with you one access
point you know people who want to be
entrepreneurs but maybe are looking for
that idea
go to that nasa technology transfer
office
the third one is you even if you have
the desire to be in space you do have to
have the right training whether that's a
certificate in advanced manufacturing or
cyber security or data analytics or a
phd
like you said from you know hidden
figures and then
you want to connect you want to connect
with like-minded individuals join
organizations like
the ones you mentioned women tech
network that's the organization that i
was
honored to receive the diversity and
inclusion officer
role model of the year from they have a
mentorship program the un
office of outer space affairs space for
women
i'm one of 35 women around the globe
that's part of that program
and again it's about mentorship and
connecting there's other programs
space generation advisory council
so look for organizations where you can
connect and then the last step is
look for a mentor and be a mentor
because no matter where you are in your
career
you can mentor someone else and you can
always look to be
mentored and coached as well so that we
can ultimately
uh you know reach our true actualization
of service before self and and helping
to contribute to the greater good
so that tells you a little bit about the
space foundation and our center for
innovation education as well as a couple
of those programs that i'm involved in
that you mentioned
no no i think that's wonderful shelley
thank you for sharing that what is the
one biggest challenge that you foresee
us having with space whether it's in
education it's in the workforce
whether it's you know one of the things
that i'm thinking about is
a lot of people are talking that if you
know in a couple hundred years we might
actually be living in an
in a different planet and how is the
world today going to impact
as the government as we see it in the
future you know we see different
countries looking
at different interests and i'm always
curious about who's thinking about this
stuff
you know who's thinking about whether my
great grandkids
are going to be a part of government x y
or whether it'll be in anarchy
right so those are great questions
and the biggest challenge i see that's
immediately impacting us
as we look to growing the space economy
in the next 10 to 20 years
is really that workforce it's um you
know do we have the right individuals
you know we have a skills deficit
we have that innovation gap and we have
a workforce shortage so as i shared with
you
there are a lot of great opportunities
in the space economy we can't find
enough workers
and so what that means is some some of
the workers we have
in the u.s maybe they're in inner cities
or rural communities or they've never
thought about being part of the space
economy
we need to inspire them to look for
opportunities to join the space economy
during covid right now individuals could
get recertified they could go through a
certificate program and go into the
manufacturing sector
data analytics cyber right now we need
that workforce
and then we have like i said the skills
mismatch we have individuals that are
looking for jobs
and we have jobs available in the space
sector in all those different industries
but we have a mismatch of skills so we
really need to look at it and the space
foundation is one organization that's
out there talking about it
but we really have to work together to
solve it government
public-private partnerships together we
can work on solving these challenges
and then of course as i shared that
innovation gap
we need entrepreneurs who want to you
know take that risk
and bring technology forward not only to
create a job for themselves
but to create jobs for others and
benefit humanity
100 one of the things that that i'm
seeing a pattern here is this
understanding you know we're educating
the market in some sense
right when you're starting a new company
when airbnb started using a space
technology of course
and they wanted people to to rent their
their houses when they're not there they
were really educating the market with a
new perception a new thinking process
because
previously it seemed weird what i'm
going to let somebody else live in my
apartment while i'm away or i'm going to
sleep in somebody else's apartment
here it sounds like there's a similar
challenge where we have you know a
generation that
needs that the space workforce needs
them but there is this
misconception of are we able to actually
be part of this workforce
and it sounds to me like yes we are and
now the question is how do we educate
the market how do you think we should go
is this is this already at the
elementary middle school age is it more
the college level
what's the sort of the thinking process
of getting this education
excellent it's actually the entire
workforce pipeline so you're right we
need to look
at kids as young as possible especially
girls and minorities
who sometimes self-eliminate in middle
school from thinking about going into
technology or space they don't see that
as a realistic
career choice so it's about taking space
inspired education
and putting it in the classroom and
that's one of the things the space
foundation does
through our center for innovation
education is we create space inspired
education
so and we do a teacher training program
so that teachers can help coach and
mentor kids
to stay on that track so that they can
go into the space economy
in in a variety of different areas and
then we also as i shared with you
it's reskilling and upskilling so we
talked to various um
workforce centers around the country and
talk about the importance of space and
how they can look at training programs
with community colleges with
universities
to reskill the workforce as workers may
be displaced by jobs that are being
automated
as technology replaces workers and how
they can have a great job
in the space economy and on average the
jobs in the space economy pay 40 percent
uh above the median income here in the
us and then of course it's about
inspiring entrepreneurship we have many
entrepreneurs that are women or
minorities
but many times they don't think about i
could be a space entrepreneur
and so again it's about breaking down
that perception that
everyone can have an opportunity to be
an entrepreneur in the space economy
whether that's food service fleet
maintenance
uh services provided through accounting
it all the way up to phds and
mathematicians there's an opportunity
and some of the programs we've done at
the space foundation
specifically do just that we have a
junior space entrepreneurship program
to inspire middle school and high school
kids to look at being entrepreneurs and
taking space technology to market
we also have our space commerce
entrepreneurship program
which is for adults for entrepreneurs to
look at
how do i find an idea i can go to the
nasa technology transfer office
or do i have a business but i want to
create another line
that i can sell to the aerospace and
space industry
and so we help them walk through what is
it to create another line of business
or to be start a new company so again
it's
that entire workforce there's a place
for everyone and we have to be
as you said breaking down those barriers
that prevent individuals from thinking
about
joining us in the space industry shelley
it's inspiring and it makes it makes so
much sense and
and i'm definitely have to do some
rethinking in mind on how i can be a
part of this
space economy because it just sounds
like you know first of all
i probably am a part of the space
economy in one way or another
just by virtue of being in all those
other industries that we mentioned in
the beginning of this episode
and but but i'm but i'm excited to take
a more active step and and
re-educate myself about what it means to
be to potentially be a part of this
workforce or be a space entrepreneur who
knows
and so thank you very much for this
inspiration it was it was phenomenal
talking to you i know how busy you are
so thank you for being so generous with
your time
and i have to ask you the most difficult
question which is three words that you
would use to describe yourself
i think i said them a few times during
the podcast
but obviously inspirational we need to
inspire
other individuals to join us in the
space economy so i would say i i strive
to be inspirational
innovative it's all about new technology
benefiting life here on earth so i
believe
innovation and then obviously agile um
the first two are great being
inspirational and innovative but you got
to be
agile and you got to get out there and
get it done and and
if you're not successful the first time
get after it again so
those would be the three ways i'd
describe myself and i would describe you
as
you are part of the space economy and
i'm grateful for the contributions
you're making
to make space a better place for
everyone here on earth
thank you very much i appreciate that
very much and so shelly thank you stay
safe and stay healthy and hopefully
we'll
see each other in space one day
i look forward to it i'll meet you on
mars definitely thank you very very much